because you've got a lot of supporters
out there musical supporters Bentley is
one of your biggest fans and supporters
what was it like opening for that guy
I can't wait for us till the end they
went they came there to watch us and
they stick around and watch Dirk
Brantley sing a few of his five oh I
mean someone called the book with war
songs that hurt my life
hey they kind of watch to us to stick
around for him just to be nice country
fans are so nice they even they don't
like you they still you know that for
you so especially up there Canada supply
and but he's fine you know he's got good
catering real toilets with porcelain
which is nice after years of uh you know
using the porta-potties of local
construction sites that we find
ourselves mark Mex it's nice to actually
have a real toilet and otherwise he just
kind of stayed the other way and just
and steals from us mostly oh yeah steals
from you like school ideas stage moves
you know that you know I'm gonna taught
him he didn't know how to do the thrust
thrust the patent yeah because you can't
see that yeah yeah yeah you praying that
properly I'm playing the guitar it's
like this I taught him that move if I
see him do that oh yeah twirl Russ these
are all moves that these are patented
Doug the Doug thrust has a TM behind his
anticip it's a trademark maneuver of
mine now I God watch his show he's
trying to go our move so he's fine he
gives the money and then he just kind of
steps aside and watch the Knights do
what they do which is just you know just
crush it like we always do you know
okay silent the key is not silent in
Terry Clark though
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dirt family loves Terry Clark he's
lonely turned us on to her
he just says she's like everything we
should try to be authentic and actually
really played the guitar leather pants
the cowboy hat the style we I really hit
it off they're pretty huh what pretty
pretty no pretty well and I'm always
have a hard spot in my heart for a soft
spot in my heart for Terry Clark
we love Canada is it really bright where
you are in your room right now I have an
extra pair just make sure I keep if I
can't find a mirror I can always kind of
just make sure I'm look back I'm not
vain I'll do it for me I'm a superstar
and I love a lot of my female fans out
there when a I'm expecting to look good
and be the fashion mobile icon that I am
so it's a little something I do just to
make sure I'm always on a game
well thanks for your time looking
forward to that moose knuckle shuffle
dance tutorials someday yeah case you
missed it let's give you one more time
here all right yeah Oh spin okay all
right well I'm gonna I'm gonna go all
right
[Music]